of course podcasts just getting more and
more popular every week everyone has a
podcast these days i've got one
andy you have one you know you know what
i do
you do yeah everyone on my crew has a
podcast
my dog has a podcast well recently
this is a big deal two hugely famous
icons president barack obama and bruce
springsteen
joined forces and started their own
podcast
yeah it's called renegades born in the
usa
yeah it's a big deal when these two get
together i gave it a listen
i have to say it's not what i expected
okay hello and welcome to renegades born
in the usa
i'm bruce springsteen and i'm barack
obama and this of course
is the podcast where we recap and talk
about our favorite show
90 day fiance that's right the boss and
me are going to cover all the big
moments of 90 day fiance
past present and future from when paolo
wanted to pose nude and move to miami in
season one to
stephanie revealing she had revenge sex
with her fiance's cousin
these are the things the american people
need to hear do you prefer the couples
who are really in love or the
fake trainwreck couples you know as a
former president i
can't condone fraudulent marriages to
obtain a green card
but as a 90-day fan you know i i love to
see it
now if you had to compare yourself and
michelle and one of those couples
who would it be uh i'd have to say amy
and dan wow
deep cut you know boss i had a lot of
stressful days as president but
nothing compares to how i feel watching
big ed and rosemary
when he tried to give her a toothbrush
and toothpaste because her breast tank
that was brutal you know what this
problem was he should have given her a
quipped
toothbrush with a sleek design and a
timer built
in quit makes sure your hygiene is at
its best
and we do thank them for their
sponsorship amen to that